welcome pin to this video against
automate okay only have one game against
this guy plate and I lost that so let's
see okay let's play the classical trying
to stay a bit more solid now night c 2 e
4 is the normal way to play you well
that's uncommon normally they take with
the night and then retreat with the
bishop okay interesting it's a very
weird way to play that we are giving up
the bishop and then opening up in
position for no particular benefit at
least that how it looks like and it's
play this I'm a little bit
underdeveloped though that's the only
thing that really can be can be sad okay
I came yeah I didn't see that move I
mean didn't really look look for a reply
c4 just looked like the move to to play
and I did not really I'm think about it
that much let's cover c4 mm yeah Bishop
f5 I possibly have 94 always have to
worry about this kind of move Bishop f5
intending 93 things like that okay it
doesn't really care it seems ok take d5
now what is the point CD Queen takes
even group checks as possible what is he
playing Knight c3 maybe
93 just queen bee too right I can take
it nonsense 93 I can just take this of
course really awkward calculation if you
can call it a calculation so we'll just
rope chicks right why not yeah now the
point or the proly problem is the
possible discovery ziam is there
something or just not be five if here 93
is also move maybe just this one
doubling I don't be as mentioned i don't
see a really great discovery by the
night
yeah what what is it what I what I
really want to achieve him would be
great to get an F 3 and E for killing
the g6 Bishop would have been
interviewed have been nice but not easy
to get it's 93 and all kinds of things
okay there's also night be fire 497 I
think this is something that I
definitely want to try to get into I get
in simply for getting rid of the d5
night and entering on the same rank
yeah it looks very nice the bishop pair
in this wide open position should really
account for quite something so night c7
is possible now but he will enter on d 2
which is awkward he might have some
discoveries
yeah hmm take sticks and then entering
on d 2 that's not really great since
some way to avoid that not really night
a 7 there is what is there not sure what
actually if i take this 93 I don't see
anything great here for him actually
after the simple captcha you can always
retreat to be five yeah maybe this one
hook a five and ruka aid or something
but ultimately I don't mind that very
much or is it that I don't have any
square with this bishop huh
and like Bishop t6 it's kind of slightly
awkward okay I cannot go to be for rupee
three looks really strange ok let's go
there it looks really strange down but I
don't see a tactical be five rupee 596
65 hanging yeah I can do that certainly
but
this shouldn't be a big issue where do I
go actually to c5 and that's not so
great where do i get with this Bishop
Thomas is also hanging here only to okay
come on that's not the best variation
but I want a simple simple thing to play
got really into into time pressure again
check can bring this I can go back to d4
with my night against that for example
it's nothing great i mean but i felt the
need to play simple mousse with the time
getting low
hmm i don't know i'm not even attacking
f7 that's not a good idea I mean it's
nothing cannot take the I mean how when
f7 I was thinking I should attack their
word doesn't really a lot thank you I
don't want to draw here I have no time I
could have played could pin me check
that's a draw draw Harvard draw a third
game wrong yeah that was very
disappointing this is a this is of
course very nice for white here around
here yeah I should should somehow get to
something substantial but I did not
manage this looks okay and yeah I
shouldn't take their probably but it
wasn't that easy it looks like excellent
but this is the first idea that comes to
mind but you all of a sudden gets very
serious calendar play that's not the way
to go the compounds to play rugby to
wear maybe that's the way to go get out
of this diagonal once that almost get
out of this diagonal once and for all
yeah thats it's probably probably good
right this is the the line that the
engine is giving with a pretty big edge
guide should be at just the bishop pair
for nothing and I have chances to really
get get to those pawns and I couldn't
find a good way here this is he somehow
gets gets play here
yeah no I didn't didn't really see a way
forward this is this is very awkward
this move but what sure what is it that
I should do well okay the comm points
out f3 okay I see it see now 93 is no
option anymore and it's not clear what
he's doing if you fear goes back then I
have a good square here yeah Andy for
coming here that's very nice actually
yeah this is what I need to do I guess
but yeah I kind of got there and got all
so far too nervous him again I should
play you for at the moment where the
night is not many can go here but I can
go there hmm thinking that this might be
might be okay IDs counter-attacks yeah
it's about its equal this year ok now I
started to struggle so are being far too
nervous yeah it's not that much going on
check but now yeah i'm here i'm in
trouble of course it look be to where
was an easy way to play sure yeah
ultimately we got to get to this Jewish
position yeah I didn't use my chances
there thanks for watching